Nvidia claims that the 5060 Ti is more
than 50 times faster than the 1060. And
if that sounds like a complete lie,
that's because it is. Think about it. If
your 1060 can run a game at 30 FPS, that
would mean that the 5060 Ti will run it
at
1,500 frames per second. How? Well, I'm
assuming is that they said max settings.
So, one, they're probably using ray
tracing, which the 1060 can't do. two,
they're probably using the 1060 3 GB
card, which definitely cannot handle
modern games. If you think about it in
that way, where the 1060 is probably
getting 2 FPS in this scenario on
average, well, then it makes a little
bit more sense that maybe the 5060 Ti is
getting around 100 FPS, though once you
take out DLSS 4x frame gen, it's more
like 25. So, does it suck? Let's unbox
it and find out. This is the PNY 5060Ti
16 GB OC. Just like the 4060 Ti, there's
going to be two versions, an 8 GB
version and a 16 GB version. Which one
you choose will probably depend on your
use case, and we'll talk about that a
little bit more later. But let's just
look at the card itself. It's a flow
through cooler design, and it has some
interesting choices in its construction.
One, look at the PCB right here. It's
like completely blank. They really just
extended it long enough so that they
could make sure that it had enough room
for the full PCIe express port. And you
can see from the traces on the back that
this is a 8x card and the rest of this
part of the connector is just kind of a
formality. On the back we have three
display port running at UHBR20 and an
HDMI port with 2.1B for speedy
connections far beyond the capabilities
of this card. Though I guess with frame
gen maybe uh you'll be able to get
those. In terms of aesthetics, I think
this card looks fine. It's pretty basic,
but that's what you'd expect for these
more budget type cards. It does have a
metal back plate that uh will help with
conducting some heat. There are thermal
pads. It's not just for show. It's a two
slot card. It could be even thinner, but
they made it two slots thick on the back
plate. And if you want to compare it to
a 4060 Ti, we got this one from Asus.
It's pretty reasonably sized. It's not
too long. It's not too thick. Will fit
into pretty much any standard case. And
look at where this power connector is.
You usually would expect the uh power
connector to be at the end of the card
towards the cutouts for like your cable
management, but over here is where the
power connector is on here, which might
actually cause an issue if you have
short cables because you have to like go
all the way here, all the way around,
all the way to the back where your power
supply might be under here. It's not
like a bad thing. It's just a little
weird. You may have noticed on the box
that this is a OC version of the card.
The good news is that that OC version is
coming in at the same price. The bad
news is that that OC is also just 4.6%.
Which isn't crazy from what we've seen
from other cards. But just take that
into consideration compared to the rest
of the 5060 Ti specs that we're showing
on screen. The 5060 Ti comes with 4,608
CUDA cores, which is more than the 4060
of last gen, but less than the 3060 Ti
two gen prior. However, the 5060 CUDA
cores and the 4060 CUDA corores are
essentially identical. So, the real
difference in performance is coming from
improvements to ray tracing, uh, AI, as
well as just higher clock speeds in
general. We also get a bump up to GDDR7.
However, on this card, we are still
limited to a 128 bit bus width. It is
kind of disappointing, but I think that
the whole bus width thing is a little
bit overblown, and we've yet to see any
of these Nvidia cards be truly
bottlenecked by their bus width. You're
also going to get access to Nvidia's
updated video engines that include
Envink and Nv. Though you'll only get
one of each. So, if you're doing really
heavy video workloads, you might find
yourself wanting for a bit more power.
And all of this is supposed to be
powered by 180 W, though they do
recommend a 600 W power supply. This OC
version doesn't have a higher power
requirement. I can't speak for other
partner models, but it's still a pretty
low power card. Though, we don't have a
5060 to test and we don't plan on
talking about it too much more in this
video. You can infer some idea of its
performance by looking at how many CUDA
cores it has relative to the TI. And the
TI has about 20% more CUDA cores. So I
wouldn't be surprised if there's a
roughly 20% difference in performance on
the 5060, maybe even a little bit more,
which would be a pretty sizable gap for
a TI card. And despite the fact that
this is an OC model, it is
MSRP supposedly at $429.
We'll see if you can get that. But how
does it perform? To figure it out, I got
John from the lab to help me. And we're
going to be drag racing a 4060 Ti and a
B580 against the 5060 Ti. Specifically
460Ti 16 GB. So why B580 instead of an
AMD card? Well, AMD doesn't really have
a price competitor that you can actually
buy. The 7700 XT has been discontinued
and the 9070 is so much more expensive
that it doesn't really feel relevant to
this card. So, the B580 is the only
other modern competitor, but if you have
old cards, we also did some testing on
those, and we'll talk about that in a
little bit. Let's get racing. And I only
just realized this, but it doesn't use
the super melty power connector that's
found on the higherend cards. It's just
a usual 8 pin. There's no RGB on this at
all. I like it. Stealthy. But you know
what isn't stealthy? This segue to our
sponsor, Java. In this age of outrageous
GPU prices and scalping, it's as good a
time as any to buy used. But can you
really trust who or where you're buying
from? Well, with Jawa, you can. Their
verified sellers are personally vetted
by the Jawua team to be a reliable
source of quality components. They even
have fully assembled ready to go builds
like this valueoriented gaming beast.
And you can offset the cost of your next
upgrade by making your own listings on
Java or even sell your GPUs and CPUs
directly to them. So don't wait. Click
our link in the description to check out
Jawa the marketplace by PC enthusiasts
for PC enthusiasts. Beat the tariffs
with the Shiptorm sale event at
ltdstore.com. We are offering free
shipping on any order worldwide over
$150. So, it's a great time to pick up a
commuter backpack, a precision
screwdriver, or a stylish framework
hoodie. Oh, I took it off to put on this
jacket. The point is, we've also got
never-before-seen pricing on our MCM
Essentials bundle. Don't miss it. We'll
have it linked down below. First up,
Cyberpunk 1080p raster, no ray tracing.
Begins in 3 2 1. So, what are you
expecting, John? Maybe 10%. Faster than
the 4060Ti 16. Yeah, but it's supposed
to be 50 times faster. Not the 1060.
Than the 1060. Yes. They didn't say how
fast it was compared to the 4060. It's
got like a pretty solid lead. We're
seeing 90 here. Maybe maybe 20%. And
that's like
118. The B580 isn't slouching, though.
On the 4060 Ti, we got an average of
101.12. On the B580, 96.53. And on the
new hotness, 127.53. Yeah. So, 20% bump.
That's quite respectable. Even more than
20%. A good start for the 5060 Ti. Let's
see. 1440p. 3 2 1. I'm mostly hearing I
think the CPU cooler. So, this is a
pretty quiet card, which makes sense cuz
it has uh a low power draw. It's about
the same as the 4060 Ti 16 GB. So, still
quite an efficient card. Wow. It's
actually doing pretty good. We have 80
on the 5060 Ti. And on the 4060 Ti, we
got
56.98, but it's being beat by the
B580 at 64. Intel actually scales
incredibly well. B580 really comes alive
with high resolution. Yeah. Interesting.
And very notable. Like remember that
this is a much much cheaper card that's
competing
with well the 4060 Ti. It's not quite
competing with this, but it's much
cheaper. Let's take a look at its RT
performance in returnal. This is at
1080p. 3 2 1 go. 4060 Ti gets 83
average, 79 average on the B580, and our
new boy gets 97 average. So again, a
pretty decent lead, like a 15 to 20ish%
lead. That's not bad, especially when
you consider that this is $70 cheaper
than the last gen card. Except for when
you also think about how the last gen
card was um probably the worst value GPU
of the past decade, which is saying a
lot cuz there's been a lot of bad value
GPUs in the past 10 years. Let's take a
moment to go through the rest of the
results that we got from Labs. On
average across our test suite at 1080,
we see the 5060 Ti pull a 15-ish% lead
over the 4060 Ti 16 gig. But against the
470 Super, it's 23% behind, which is
disappointing when you would consider
and usually expect that the nextG car to
tier down will beat the last gen card to
tier up by a healthy margin. Clearly,
that's just not true. On the one hand,
compared to last gen, it's impressive
that it's getting this much of an uplift
with only having 6%ish more CUDA cores,
but it's still just disappointing. In
the 1440 raster, we see pretty similar
margins with the 5060 Ti getting about
17% uplift over the 4060 Ti 16 GB. I
hate how I have to specify it. And the
RTX 4070 Super pulls away with a
slightly larger lead. The B580 is
supposed to be barely half the price of
this 5060 Ti. To be getting just 20%
less performance while saving that much
money is pretty compelling. Sure, the
B580 has driver problems, but the 5000
series has been having its own share of
driver problems. Not as bad, but it's
worth considering though. I guess what
are your other options? It's not like
AMD has an option yet. Let's talk about
RT though. Rate tracing 1080. The 5060
Ti, it's worse. The 4060 Ti 16 GB closes
the gap to closer to 15% while the 5060
Ti trails even further behind the 4070
Super in ray tracing. For 1440 RT, we
kind of felt that that was outside of
the parameters of what this card is
designed for, but we wanted to check it
out anyways. And in Cyberpunk, well, it
gets, you won't believe this, roughly
30% behind the 4070 Super and roughly
15% in front of the 4060 Ti 16 gig. For
thermals, the PNY 5060Ti 16 GB performs
adequately with a of roughly 69 average
degrees C temperatures. And in F1, we
see a max temp of 68 and a average of
65. In terms of power draw, we're seeing
a similar trend to other Blackwell GPUs
where yes, they perform around their
average rated power rating, but they do
like to pull a little bit extra with the
most we ever saw it pulling across our
tests being around 213 watts,
substantially higher than the 180 watt
TGP. Wow, Nvidia, you've done it again.
You've released another dud and you did
it all in style while completely lying
and misrepresenting your performance.
Sure, DLSS4 it's good, especially the
upscaler. Frame gen is neat and works
nicely in specific scenarios, but comes
with its own downsides. So, what is
Nvidia really offering us here that we
don't already have? 50 bucks in savings
and that's it on a card that already
sucks in value. We haven't tested the
5060Ti 8 gigabyte version, so we don't
know if the 16 gigabyte version gets you
that much more performance, and we also
don't know what the 5060 is going to
look like. So, considering that those
have their own price gaps, who knows if
the 5060 Ti 16 gig is going to be good.
The GPU market right now is rough and
all we can do is wait and see. Maybe in
a few months prices will settle and we
can be happy that there's at least some
cards that are available on the lower
price ranges because it's been a desert
for the past several months. So, that's
something to be thankful for. And I'm
thankful for you for watching this short
circuit. If you like this format, why
don't you check out our 5080 roundup
where we looked at three different
5080s. Yeah, they're expensive, but if
you're going to spend that much money,
you might as well know which one to